non c'è nulla di più inventato della
cucina tradizionale e niente di più
globale del cibo locale per secoli
mangiare cibo locale è stato una delle
condanne dell'umanità
i nostri trisnonni preistorici
cacciatori raccoglitori si nutrivano di
quello che trovavano nella foresta nella
giungla uno spazio limitato si muovevano
solo quando si erano mangiati le risorse
e seguendo le mandrile animali che
cacciavano con il fuoco con i bastoni
con l'arco e con le frecce gli
agricoltori del neolitico per primi
immaginarono una modalità di produzione
del cibo basata sulla selezione di semi
delle piante più produttive e resistenti
come l'orzo il grano il riso il grano
turco intaccando così per la prima volta
la biodiversità che troviamo in natura
in un bosco in un prato e così
diventarono i primi contadini sedentari
i cereali avevano il grande vantaggio di
essere conservabili nei granai
permettendo così alle prime società
agricole di pianificare le strategie di
sopravvivenza e di liberare braccia e
menti per altre attività che non fossero
lavorare la terra
nacquero così i profeti gli scriba e
scienziati soldati le città e lo stato
naturale grandi sottile civiltà che
percependo siccome superiore ai barbari
che continuavano a muoversi sul
territorio inventano il pregiudizio
contro i migranti e nacquero anche le
classi sociali e l'elite che erano le
uniche a potersi permettere un cibo non
locale i ricchi patrizi romani
mangiavano una cucina globale senza
stagioni grazie a prodotti che
arrivavano tutto l'impero così come le
grandi corti europee del medioevo che
esprimevano il loro potere e prestigio
utilizzando grandi quantità di spezie
che arrivavano dalle lontane isole
dell'oceano indiano attraverso strade
tortuosissima pericolose risultando così
carissime tutto il resto della
popolazione
la grande maggioranza della popolazione
la massa contadina si sbagliava con un
cibo locale localissimo il più delle
volte un solo cereale il riso bari
cinesi il mais mesoamericane il frumento
per i popoli mediterranei
infatti anche il cibo
esco di stagione era una prerogativa dei
ricchi prima dello scatto lamento della
refrigerazione industriale il cibo
deperiva velocemente frutta e verdura
marcivano pochi giorni dopo il raccolto
ed erano necessarie tecniche pre
industriali di lavorazione per
trasformare il latte in formaggio o la
carne i salumi conservare il cibo farlo
durare nel tempo per non patire la fame
è stata la grande sfida di generazioni e
generazioni di contadini che dovevano
per forza di cose mangiare cibo locale
solo l'industrializzazione alimentare
che ha spostato il luogo d'origine del
cibo dei campi e delle case in fabbriche
lontane di cui il consumatore finale sa
poco o nulla ha reso il cibo locale
buono da mangiare e buono da pensare
soprattutto è stata paradossalmente la
grande globalizzazione alimentare della
fine del novecento che ha portato un
cibo originario da ogni angolo del mondo
sugli scaffali dei supermercati e su
migliori di tavole a introdurre una vera
e propria mistica del cibo locale
tradizionale
bisogna dire che la preferenza per il
cibo km 0 rispecchia giustissimo e
preoccupazioni ambientali del nostro
tempo il trasporto su lunghe distanze di
cibo per terra mare e aria
è quanto di più insostenibile si possa
immaginare
la distanza più breve tra luogo di
produzione luogo di consumo a contrario
permette al consumatore di conoscere
meglio ciò che ingerisce nel proprio
corpo attraverso la conversazione con i
produttori come avviene per esempio quel
gruppi di acquisto solidale e con i
venditori nei mercati contadini e nei
mercati della terra in un'altra
accezione però il discorso più politico
e anche più complicato e controverso la
globalizzazione alimentare se quella
dall'alto delle grandi corporation
multinazionali alimentari delle grandi
catene fast food sia dal basso in
prodotte dai migranti che a milioni si
spostano da una parte all'altra del
pianeta hanno portato per reazione alla
valorizzazione senza precedenti delle
ricette dei cibi dei cibi e teramo
locali nell'ambito di un idea difensiva
è conservatrice dell'identità durante la
campagna elettorale per le presidenziali
americane del 2016 un sostenitore di
donald trump ha programmato alla
televisione su entusia
massimo per il muro che candidato
repubblicano aveva permesso di costruire
tra stati uniti e messico sostenendo che
i messicani si infiltrano ovunque la
loro cultura estremamente aggressiva li
dobbiamo fermare
avremo venditori di tacos a ogni angolo
di strada
il discorso che immagina la cucina
nazionale come qualcosa di puro ed
eterno e che va difesa da contaminazioni
escludendo il diverso non è solo
pericoloso ma si fonda su base storica
inconsistenti le nostre tradizioni
alimentari il nostro cibo locale sono il
prodotto di secolari migrazioni di
piante animali di cibi e di persone gli
infiniti scambi ed una mobilità globale
che non comprende solo il viaggio di
individui poveri in cerca di un futuro
migliore ma anche di mercanti e delle
loro merci
i soldati marinai missionari turisti se
si va indietro nel tempo si vede che
nessuna cucina autentica perché tutti o
quasi i suoi ingredienti arrivano da
qualche altra parte
il nostro abitudini alimentari sono
creature delle migrazioni il nostro
locale e globale
la più grande trasmigrazione di cibi
della storia il cosiddetto scambio
colombiano se il movimento bidirezionale
di piante animali e germi tra vecchio e
nuovo mondo avvenuto a seguito
dell'arrivo degli europei nelle americhe
nel 1492 per effetto dello scambio
dell'eurasia dell'africa arrivarono in
america piante importanti come il grano
il riso il caffè e lo zucchero di cui
gli europei impiantarono le piantagioni
a loro uso e consumo utilizzando il
lavoro forzato degli scavi africani
un'altra migrazione è un numero
imponente di animali addomesticati
dalla mucca al maiale alla pecora alla
capra al pollo a cavallo il più
americano di tutti i cibi globali che
pensi che è possibile immaginare la
murga di manzo quindi non è tecnicamente
americano dall'america il vecchio mondo
ricevette due fondamentali prodotti
ammazza fame altamente produttivi e
ricchi di carboidrati come la patata e
il mais che ebbero un ruolo fondamentale
nel sostenere la crescita della
popolazione mondiale in particolare a
quella europea
durante il corso dell'ottocento quindi
il manifesto elettorale della lega nord
di qualche anno fa intitolato sia la
polenta no al cus
cus che si riferisce la necessità di
fermare l'immigrazione dei paesi
musulmani anche con mezzi culturali
gastronomici e storicamente parlando
infondato futuro nella seconda metà del
settecento che i contadini e il nord
italia controvoglia peraltro adottavano
la coltivazione del mais una pianta
americana che però arrivava in italia
dall'oriente ottomano da cui il nome
granoturco per farne loro cibo
quotidiano sotto forma di polenta il
grano duro al contrario è stato un
abitante nel mediterraneo per millenni e
le prime tracce del couscous nell'area
di questa ragione risalgono al 1300
dato il numero degli immigrati nord
africani impiegati nelle aziende
agroalimentari italiane tra l'altro è
difficile pensare che quel granoturco e
quella polenta cui si riferisce il
manifesto non siano passate attraverso
le loro mani
ancora più difficile è immaginare la
cucina italiana in particolare quella
nel sud del paese senza altri due piante
originarie dell'america il pomodoro il
peperoncino
diversamente dal mais la patata questi
due queste due piante non forniscono
quasi per nulla calorie
eppure una volta introdotti nella
cultura alimentare locale sono serviti a
creare un intero universo del gusto
legato strettamente all'immaginario
globale dell'italianità e degli italiani
grazie alla creatività di cuoche pochi
popolari il mezzogiorno in italia il
pomodoro americano contribuito a
proseguire due piatti i codici della
cucina italiana come la pasta la pizza e
il vettore della globalizzazione di
questi due piatti hills e pasta è stata
la migrazione di massa italiana della
svolta del novecento il pomodoro così
viaggio al contrario verso l'america
insieme ai tre milioni di me e mezzo di
italiani emigrati tra il 1890 e il 1924
colorando di fatto di rosso la cucina
americana
un secolo dopo il pomodoro italiano è
stato ulteriormente globalizzato dalla
forza lavoro internazionale che ne
permette la stessa esistenza
le migliaia di lavoratori migranti
africani ed est europei che lo
raccolgono sotto il sole del mezzogiorno
le migrazioni quindi sono tutt'altro che
una minaccia al cibo le cucine mercati
nazionali
alle migrazioni dobbiamo spesso alla
salvaguardia e il recupero di antiche
tradizioni in alcuni paesi della val
padana alla totalità dei mungitori delle
bacche dal cui latte si producono il
grana padano e il parmigiano reggiano
sono indiani sikh
senza di loro questo in due celine
secolare tradizione smetterebbe
semplicemente di funzionare il discorso
nazionalista localista che fa prevalere
la memoria e il luogo sull'elemento
umano e fa scomparire allo sguardo al
palato è la mente alla percezione delle
mani non italiane che hanno
effettivamente fatto due prodotti tipici
del made in italy come il pomodoro san
marzano il parmigiano reggiano identità
autenticità sono concetti mentali
sentirsi parte in un'azione una cultura
immutabile è una professione di fede
basata su una falsa percezione nulla
meglio della storia del cibo ci mostra
come in realtà la variazione se la norma
da un punto di vista puramente e
oggettivo
niente è davvero autentico il locale a
denominazione di origine controllata e
definito come tale attraverso parametri
arbitrari e talvolta artificiose la
prossima volta che vi sarete a tavola o
che fate la spesa che cucinate fateci
caso e noterete quanto lo scambio tra
luoghi e culture diverse sia
fondamentale per la materia prima della
nostra esistenza grazie vecchie
[Applauso]